we're keeping the banks in the dark what
do we know if on that's right more
evidence if it was needed that just
because Beijing comes out with a policy
it doesn't mean that the provincial
governments are going to follow suit and
this is a case where these local
governments it seems a number of them
have drawn up lists of zombie companies
in their jurisdictions but are holding
back on revealing those to the bank's
this comes about after we heard from the
head of ICBC and Jiang Shi Province who
said there was a list of zombie
companies there that he wanted to get
his hands on zombie companies companies
that are overburdened with debt
struggling with over capacity and
effectively are due to be written off at
some stage so it's just fascinating that
this is happening and it's also the case
we've heard that banking regulators and
some of these provinces are also being
kept in the dark and the context of
course for all of this is a rising tide
of bad loans here in China at levels
last seen since 2005 if you bring up the
terminal we've got a chart that shows
this this rising tide of bad loans in
fact we're at levels above where the
Agricultural Bank of China in 2008 was
bailed out we're actually closing in on
2005 and the height of bad loans where
ICBC itself had to receive a capital
injection so that is the context and
those are the official numbers of course
there are many analysts out there who
say that the rate of bad loans is
actually far far higher Tom that's
incredible and certainly a warning sign
they're just looking at that one chart
so what does all this mean for official
efforts to wind companies up and tackle
this overcapacity problem but I think it
really points to the challenges facing
the central government as they try to
pull back and rein in these mad loans
but also to restructure these SOE these
state-owned enterprises and tackle these
zombie firms McKinsey has put out the
consultancy a number that really stands
out they say that China's economy could
actually grow by an additional have an
additional five point six trillion
dollars of
growth added to it if they tackle
sectors like coal steel and cement if
they really push through those reforms
that five point six trillion been added
between now and 2030 according to
McKinsey but of course there's the pain
as well there are other analysts who say
that they could be a hundred and eighty
billion dollars of additional bad loans
that are added if these reforms are
pushed through and in shanxi province
itself where we would win as I mentioned
earlier where the ICBC head has been
having problems getting hold of this
list they've already said they're going
to close 205 coal mines they are of
course faced with the prospect of
massive job losses tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands of people that's
the dilemma they face and from the
central government here there is a
dilemma as well and diverging voices
from the People's Bank of China and the
NDRC that powerful oversight group so it
is a tricky tricky problem Betty